on va essayer de faire le tour des
questions qui reviennent le plus souvent
avec hélène bourdages présidente de
l'association montréalaise des
directions d'établissement scolaire mme
bourdages bonsoir bonsoir monsieur alors
j'ai quelques questions très simple vous
allez me donner les réponses que vous
allez donner aux parents et quand vous
adonner à québec dans certains cas à la
première question qu'arrive-t-il si il y
à un camp dans la classe de notre enfant
si un corps dans la classe il ya locale
qui est prévu à cet effet et l'enfant
est isolé avec une personne on appelle
le parrain la personne mais tous les
équipements de protection l'appelle le
parent qui vient chercher le jeune et
après pour les pour les gens qui
l'entouraient
cet enfant là qu'ils auraient développé
la coved et une fois qu'on a un test
positif qu est ce qui arrive au reste du
groupe ce qui a déjà été dit ce qui
aurait elle pour tous les élèves de
l'école d'une lettre à 10 ans qui ont un
code de conduite positif dans l'école et
il y aurait pour cette classe une lettre
disant que cette lan sur un code qu vite
donc on éviterait l'ensemble du groupe à
se faire tester à se faire tester mais
on continue avec le cours continue dans
la classe jeux wii gb et que cela en
fait ce matin la santé publique lancée à
nouveau une nouvelle plateforme pour
l'auto évaluation donc pas on ne se
vendant du docteur arruda dire on peut
rester des gens qui n'ont pas de
symptômes donc le test d'autoévaluation
c'est pour se gouverner justement si le
nez collé ce que j'envoie mon enfant à
l'école ou pas donc c'est ce test
d'autoévaluation qui pourra justement
aider tous les parents à se gouverner ce
que je n'envoie l'école est ce que je le
vois pas l'école donc ça va être la
santé publique qui va prendre
une fois que les gens les parents auront
eu ce message de code dans la classe
d'accord mais que fait il ya pas de code
dans la classe et qu'un membre de la
famille des symptômes de qui ressemble à
un rhume
le père la mère le frère et la soeur
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on on la voit
qu'en qu'est ce que vous dites aux
parents on la voit ta que le jeune n'a
pas de symptômes
mais encore là c'est ce nouveau ce
nouvel outil d'auto-évaluation
loqueffret frais frais ça vient de
sortir d'être mis en ligne ce matin
c'est kobe 2009 québec auto-évaluation
alors ça ça va permettre aux gens
justement d'évaluer pis là dessus on
peut voir lors que ce n'est pas la
tranche d'âge donc un enfant de 5 à 10
euros les mêmes symptômes que des
canadiens mais c'est pas les mêmes
conséquences donc ça permettre aux gens
de se gouverner bon et si l'enfant qui
doit aller à l'école parce que
normalement dans la vie preco vite quand
quelqu'un valeureux mais je sens un
petit minet qui coule pas de température
on pouvait souvent l'envoyer à l'école
quand même là qu'est ce que vous dites
aux paras qui vous disent monde on a
faim il y en ait qui colle qu'est ce que
je fais mais ce que je ferai le sait
qu'avec justement ce test
d'autoévaluation on se comprend il ya
pas vu de médecin encore pire on le sait
pas dans le fond la recommandation c'est
d'attendre 24 ha et là on revoit le test
d'autoévaluation pour voir si la
situation s'améliore l'eau se détériore
évidemment on comprend qu'on commence à
faire de la fière on dit d'ailleurs que
si c'est juste le nez qui coule le
masque qui sera obligatoire pour les
déplacements mais pas obligatoire en
classe ça c'est clair pour tout le monde
ces cas pour tout le monde masque est
obligatoire dans tous les déplacements
pour les enfants partir de la cinquième
année là du début du troisième cycle et
pour tous les adultes évidemment tous
les adultes de l'école doivent montrer
l'exemple
moi je d'ailleurs j'ai bon espoir que
justement le vivre ensemble
à l'école on va apprendre à vivre avec
covit dans l'école mais c'est sûr qu'on
est super content de retourner dans nos
écoles lahoud pauvres les élèves depuis
depuis très très longtemps
je compte vous disiez ça parce que c'est
normal puis les nouvelles dont on met
l'accent souvent sur les inquiétudes qui
sont les questions qu'il faut faire ça
mais bon on passe peut-être un peu trop
sous silence les l'excitation qui a
autour de cette rentrée aussi puis
notamment dans la grande région de
montréal parce qu'ailleurs les l'école
avait recommencé
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont très hâte
de revoir leurs élèves de continuer à
enseigner les élèves sera d'aller à
l'école etc
faut pas l'oublier ce non plus bon j'en
viens au masque combien de masse qu'on
donne à l'enfant au moins deux j'imagine
et on sentait le se découvre découvre
visage qu'ils ont encore deux ans demain
avec oui au moins de un mois des enfants
qui ont déjà perdu des affaires dans
l'école c'est déjà arrivé
donc oui je fasse pour faire une petite
provision de masques puis oui son insu
remercier mouiller et puis tout ça comme
cela en aura un autre donc au moins deux
avant qu'il parte
comment seront organisées les
récréations sa venue beaucoup dans les
questions qu'on a reçues c'est c'est
toujours l'idée du groupe fermé à ont
fait dans les cours d'école on a fait
des marquages donc le groupe jouant
ensemble et ça airs des cordes à danser
pour les filles des ballons pour les
garçons un autre lance pas trop loin le
cb sexus que je viens de lui parce que
le contraire mais je vais suivre
essentiellement on va être donc
dangereux car et pour la classe et s'il
n'y a pas assez de corée pour la casse
dans l'espace mais on va faire plus
qu'une récréation
mais chose parce que j'ai encore déjà
question sur les dîners dans les dunes
c'est pareil il y aura peut-être deux
trois dîners pour permettre ce qui est
pas trop de gens en même temps dans les
espaces communs non pas justement les
donc vous n'avez pas trop de crainte que
ça devienne compliqué à gérer
on va partir avec l'espoir et on est
quand même on n'a pas de lit comme non
plus là on va partir avec des modalités
un peu serré l'a exigé des choses
maintenant si jamais la santé publique
trouve que les combes et c'est bien ils
nous donneront des conseils plus haut si
jamais la santé publique trouve qu'il ya
des régions sont plus contaminés bah ils
nous donneront des consignes plus
strictes
on commence à en discuter vraiment
beaucoup de choses je sais pas si ça
vous pu la sauver les gens mais j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de succès tant avec la
santé publique la csst qui s'occupe des
travailleurs et l'éducation pour
travailler ensemble pour permettre de
rentrer sécuritaire et se remettre donc
à l'apprentissage
le service de garde comme j'ai pas des
gens des élèves qui viennent de la même
classe comment on fait pour réparer par
groupe il ya deux exceptions à la bulle
classe 1 puis d'ailleurs quand la bulle
classe devenu la bulle classe là on
était très content que ce soit plus les
tubules dans la classe il ya deux
exceptions au à la bulle de classe
c'est le service de garde et les élèves
de 4e 5e secondaire qui pourrait être
jumelé pour avoir une option donc au
service de garde
un peu comme on l'a dit dans les
services de garde urgence ça se peut
qu'aider des élèves de plus qu'une
classe à ce moment là prévient hélène
bourdages merci beaucoup avait été très
clair puis finalement on va on y va à
tâtons même si un plan très précis pour
verhoek les gens vont s'ajuster au
président alors bonne rentrée bonne
rentrée scolaire pour vos enseignants
pour les élèves qui nous écoutent tous
les parents qui on veut regarder un peu
demain comment ça s'est passé au cours
des prochaines semaines
merci mais c'est vous benoîtement